when you were pitching mission park with
Brian and you were hearing these nose
and you were hearing that the cast
should be changed slightly yes to have
what they thought would be non-latinos
non-latinos yes what were the reasons
that they were giving you why did they
think that that would enhance the
success well when we created the
business plan we needed to add projects
that were successful to compare them to
ours and there weren't any projects
films that had a predominantly Latino
cast that were successful there just
aren't as many desperado maybe one and
you know I'm mariachi but those are like
far and few between and they're
different from Mission Park so when you
don't have something to show them that
oh this is marketable it's very tough
sell the catch-22 is that no one's
casting Latinos so if you don't put them
in these films to give them the
opportunity to achieve success then they
never will and therefore you will never
have the projects to compare when you're
trying to pitch projects with Latinos
and that was a difficult aspect of it
now this last weekend instructions not
included I mean you just need to put
that on the business plan and save
twenty five percent of the Latinos who
went to the movies this les we can help
that film make 10 milli
in 300 theaters now you have it so we
can see that it's coming it's a wave its
tidal wave and it's coming and it's full
of Latinos also too did they talk about
the roles who they wanted in certain
roles in terms of typecasting and in
terms of because I know two of the roles
or their agents right of the four
friends and then to our people that are
maybe were drug dealing or in gangs or
something like that yes it's more a sort
of an organized crime and they were ok
with a Latino being the bad guy or the
sexy you know leading lady or maybe even
the sidekick but not the lead that
belongs to a non Latino and Jeremy ray
Valdez was perfect for this part and we
just weren't going to not cast him in it
so we kept moving forward and said
listen we know that there aren't any
films like this out there but we hope to
be first and like I said now with the
recent success of instructions not
included with a you know very well known
Mexican actor and this is the number to
film in America you know this last
weekend with like I said Mexican actor
and it's predominantly in Spanish in
America an American film predominantly
in Spanish was number two so you look at
that you're like things are changing and
when I went to all the AMC theaters to
make sure that the things we're running
smoothly in terms of they had all the
elements for our release on September 6
that film was sold out and there were so
many
my Latino people in line so many they
left gone to the movies we love going to
the movies and I think it's only fair
that if they spend all their money going
to see movies they should at least be
able to see themselves not only in the
theaters but on the big screen and
thankfully that that is happening it
doesn't mean that the white people going
to fade away it just means that there's
going to be a nice balance and that
there's going to be an even share to
sort of have everyone's story up on the
screen from many different backgrounds
my Asian brothers you know as well they
also want to be represented and all that
so we need just different stories and
mission park is a different story and
it's told our way and and with talented
American Latino actors who are worthy of
being on the big screen as any other
actor they really give solid
performances and now people can say that
there aren't any good Latino actors in
Hollywood there are I cast some of them
you